- [Mark] All right, Honey?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Honey, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Compton, California.
- [Mark] Yup. And you grew
up with both of your parents?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Tell me about your
childhood. You had to...
- Well my childhood is like bad, but like,
I don't like that gets me low. You know?
- [Mark] In what ways was it bad?
- Like I basically been
through sexual abuse,
physical, mentally, emotional.
- [Mark] Kind of from, from your parents?
- From both my parents.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff was going on?
- Like, my dad would like
touch me inappropriately
when my mom wasn't there.
And my mom would like hit
me and shit, upside my head.
So
- [Mark] Did you ever tell
anybody about this growing up?
- No, I haven't.
- [Mark] So you're, you're how old?
- I'm seventeen.
- [Mark] Seventeen.
And how long have you've
been on the street?
- I've been in the street for three years.
- [Mark] So at fourteen.
Did you, did you finish high school?
- No.
- [Mark] Did you go to high school at all?
- Yes, I did.
- [Mark] How many years did you go there?
- Two.
- [Mark] Two.
So now you're living where?
You're on the street?
- I'm on the street.
- [Mark] In a tent?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And so what are you
doing to support yourself?
- I basically sell my body
to make money and shit.
To support myself, to give
me food and shit I need,
clothes and shit.
- [Mark] Right.
So you'll, you'll just
pick up guys on the street.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And are you
using any of the drugs
that are around here?
- Yes. I use crystal meth.
- [Mark] Crystal meth?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What age were you
when you first started using drugs?
- Thirteen.
- [Mark] Thirteen?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] And do you think,
do you have any contact
with your family at all?
- No.
- [Mark] When's the last time
you spoke to your parents?
- They're, they're dead.
- [Mark] They're dead?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] How'd you lose your parents?
- My, my dad got shot
because my dad was affiliated
and my mom she died of natural causes.
- [Mark] When you say
natural causes, like what?
- Like she was, she was old.
She died of natural causes.
- [Mark] So your dad, when
you say affiliated, I mean
he was in one of...
- He was a gang member.
- [Mark] Gang member.
Is he Mexican?
- Black.
- [Mark] Black.
So your dad is black?
- Yes. He's my stepdad.
- [Mark] Stepdad. Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And do you have any siblings?
- No.
- [Mark] You were the only child?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Do you have
any grandparents, uncle?
- No. I have two kids.
- [Mark] Well you have
two children of your own?
- Yes.
Two, a daughter and a son.
My daughter died two days ago.
My son's in the hospital sick right now.
- [Mark] What did your daughter die of?
- She had the Corona.
She caught the Corona.
- [Mark] And died?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] And are you worried
about catching it or?
- No.
- [Mark] Were you in her life?
- Yes, I was in her life, but her, her dad
he died two years before
her third birthday.
- [Mark] So when she
contracted coronavirus,
how long ago was that?
- Well, she caught it a month ago,
but they they finally told
me she died two days ago.
My mom, my, my mom, she
called me my step-mom.
She called me and she told
me my daughter was dead.
- [Mark] And how do you feel about that?
- I feel really hopeless right now.
Cause she was, she was
she was the only thing that
was keeping me motivated.
So it was the only thing that did that.
Won't bring me back to
old life I used to live.
- [Mark] So you have no family?
- No I don't.
- [Mark] And your daughter
passed away and your son.
- He's sick.
- [Mark] He's sick. What is he sick with?
- They say he has an
immune system infection.
- [Mark] He's in the hospital right now.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Do you visit him?
- No.
- [Mark] Who, who takes care of your,
who took care of your two children?
- My step-mom.
- [Mark] Your step-mom.
So you're not really in the kids' lives?
- Not anymore.
- [Mark] (heaves) So where,
what are you hoping to do here?
You're 17 and you're living on the street.
You're using crystal meth.
You've lost touch with your kids.
You've lost one of your
kids and your parents.
- Like,
to be honest I really
don't like how I was raised
and where I was raised at
and what I am today.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm trying to change, but
it's going to be hard for me.
I just need the right help and
the right people by my side.
- [Mark] What do you think you need?
Therapy.
- Therapy, rehab.
I'm Trying to go back to college.
- [Mark] And finish high school?
Finish high school go back
to, then go to college.
Get my own apartment,
basically set goals, good goals.
Instead of do the, the
shit that I do right now.
- [Mark] So you're picking up guys.
How often do you do that?
- Everyday.
- [Mark] Everyday.
But down here on Skid Row,
you get all kinds of people, right?
- Yes I do.
- [Mark] Do you have any
terrible stories about that?
- No.
I don't have no stories.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Cause I aint proud of what I'm doing.
- [Mark] But nobody gives you a hard time?
- They do.
- [Mark] That's what I,
that's what I'm talking about.
Stories.
Like what kind of bad
things have happened to you?
- Well, basically there was
this one trip that I did
and he took me to his hotel room
and basically he forced
me to have sex with him.
And when I tried to run off
he grabbed me by my hair
and started hitting me in my face.
And I had to call one of my homeboys
from my set to come and pick me up.
And my homeboy's locked up right now
because he smashed his
head in with the hammer.
- [Mark] Did he kill him or did he just?
- He killed him
My homeboy's doing life right now.
- [Mark] You've been arrested
for any of those stuff.
- Yes, I have.
I been arrested for a robbery,
battery, prostitution, drug dealing
and false ID and false,
and false identification.
- [Mark] When the police
discovered that you're under age,
did they do anything about that?
Did they treat you differently?
- Yeah, they did.
They did.
- [Mark] Is there
anywhere they can take you
or they just set you free?
- They just set me free.
I did my time.
I did four months in jail and I got out.
- [Mark] Do you have any, I mean,
do you get hopeless sometimes?
Do you get depressed?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] I would think your, your history
and what's going on in
your life right now.
- Yeah, people think I'm crazy because
of what I've been through
and how I react to it.
You know?
- [Mark] What's, what's the
hardest part of your life?
- When I lost my daughter?
- [Mark] Well, that, that
was like two days ago.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Would you be going to a funeral
or something like that?
How old was she?
- She was three.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends, Honey?
- No.
- [Mark] Anybody you trust in your life?
- Yeah. People from my set.
- [Mark] You're set being your gang.
- Yeah my gang.
- [Mark] And your gang is a black gang,
a Hispanic gang?
- Black.
- [Mark] Okay.
From Compton?
- Nah.
Swan family blood.
- [Mark] What do you
wish had been different
about your childhood?
- I wish I could have grew up differently,
than to grow up to be how I am now.
- [Mark] Can you say the
living down here on the street
is probably going to keep
you from getting high school
and you know.
- Yeah. It is.
- [Mark] Are you hoping to,
are trying to get out of here?
- I'm trying.
- [Mark] You have nobody to
no, no, no support system.
Right?
- Nope.
People ain't say who people
and the people who you think they are.
- [Mark] So living on the
streets since you were 14,
what kind of things have happened to you
just from being homeless?
- I've been molested.
I've been gang raped before.
Started using crystal
and basically fucked up my life,
doing the shit that I'm doing now
and losing my daughter
makes me think about
why I have a purpose in the world.
- [Mark] What kind of thoughts
go through your head sometimes?
Do you get, you get suicidal or like that?
Sometimes?
- No, I don't get suicidal.
I just get depressed.
And I just think about
all the people I lost.
What I could've done to
prevent what happened to me.
- [Mark] What, what do you
think you could have done?
- I don't know.
I wish I could to just grow up
and not be the person I am right now.
- [Mark] Yeah, you know you
never had much of a chance.
- Nope.
- [Mark] What was your daughter's name?
- Colin.
- [Mark] And what was,
what's your son's name?
- Marco.
- [Mark] Will you be visiting your son
while he's in the hospital?
- No. They wouldn't let me.
- [Mark] They won't let you?
Why is that?
- Because what I'm doing
right now.(sobbing)
- [Mark] What do you think
would help you the most,
right now?
- [Honey] I'm just hoping God
will give me another chance
to be there for my son and my mom.
- [Mark] All right, Honey.
Well, thank you for talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] Yeah, you
definitely could use a break.
Couldn't you.
- No, I'm okay.